uh night two worst infomercial ever also
we call it the 2020 dnc adam shift show
let's put it that way past two nights
just heard nothing but several democrats
touting biden and his campaign's far
left agenda
more left than any major political party
in history
2016 republican presidential candidate
john kasich's madness
here with reaction all of this senior
white house adviser kellyanne conway
kellyanne
i'm sure you have one or two things to
say about all this
hey sean thanks for having me four years
ago i was with you in philadelphia the
democratic convention and we would say
wow have you ever seen such a
grievance-filled
candidate nominee that's feckless and
reckless and cantankerous and the answer
is
yes even more so now you've got joe
biden
who beat all these socialist radical
ideas in the primary and the candidates
who carried them now capitulating and
congratulating to the same people
and it looks a little bit like a swamp
reunion to me for a convention that's
supposed to be about the people and for
the people
you've got lots of folks who have been
in and of washington
for decades bill clinton they gave him
less than five minutes tonight if you
look at the average time that he's
spoken over the last say seven
eight democratic conventions 60 some
minutes 25 minutes 48 minutes
his role has shrunk in the party because
the party that he tried to be a moderate
in no longer exists
it has been taken over by the squad that
doesn't do squat
it's been taken over by the bernie by
the manifesto and i think most
importantly
the person mentioned most at the biden
convention is not joe biden
it's donald trump trump trump trump it's
every it's every noun verb and adverb
out of their mouths
it tells you that the democratic party
itself has no
confidence in the competence of their
nominee joe biden they missed their
moment
joe biden as the nominee means that
donald trump
continues to run as the outsider the
underdog the underestimated
outsider even though he's the incumbent
president usually the challenger to the
incumbent owns the mantle of outsider
that cannot possibly be true if you've
got joe biden
who has done less than 47 years in
washington than donald trump has done
47 months in washington you and i live
and breathe and need politics and have
for decades right
okay there's never been a major
political party
this radical how will the country accept
it whether they try to hide it or not
hide it i mean he's
he's embraced it he's owned it and and
clearly i guess
believes in it or else he wouldn't have
done it
we already know what the public thinks
if you look at polling on issues which
is always much more telling than horse
race ballot questions because those
change over time
as people solidify their votes and take
a look at the candidates and make their
decisions
but if you look at policy questions
americans reject everything the green
new deal stands for it's expensive it's
intrusive it's invasive
it's just the worst of the federal
government banning cows and gas and air
travel and the like
in fact when it went to a vote in the
united states senate sean do you recall
how many votes that green new deal got
zero zero including among the democrats
who were running for it
president at the time who said that they
wanted to support it it got zero votes
when they actually had to go back and
tell their constituents we support this
we know abortion the ninth month is a
nonstarter we know raising our taxes you
know the business tax went from 35
percent down to 21
under president trump and if you raise
it back up again
millions of americans will lose their
jobs we know that people don't want the
big lie of the last 10 years you can
keep your plan keep your doctor to
continue under joe biden it's president
trump the healthcare president
who's been trying to stabilize these
exchanges and make health care more
affordable more accessible so if you
look at issues polling
the democratic party right now is way
out of step with where americans are
that's why it's very odd that joe biden
who beat down all those
issues and beat down all those policies
and the people who stood for them
is is rolling back to the center rolling
back to the hard left
and doing that look if you look at all
the footage of joe biden bragging about
with bill clinton his vote on nafta
donald trump's done away with that with
the usmca much better for this country
for job creators job seekers job holders
much better for mexico
much better for canada much better for
the united states of america look at joe
biden and bill clinton
bragging about their big crime bill in
1994
it's president trump who's enacted
criminal justice reform such that people
who are overcharged and over sentenced
have a second chance at life and we will
be highlighting a number of those people
next week at our people's convention you
will see people who have been
consequently
measurably impacted in their lives
because president trump
is in the oval office and his commander
in chief and that's really the story of
his presidency
all right kellyanne always good to see
you thank you for being with us